en este vídeo quiero hablar acerca de
otra de las ideas que es muy poco
comprendida con respecto a los impuestos
y se refiere a la deducción y una de las
deducciones de impuestos más comunes es
la deducción que se obtiene del interés
hipotecario digamos que este año en mini
potec a la parte de mi hipoteca que
tiene intereses digamos que es de diez
mil dólares
de los intereses
en mi hipoteca
y a lo mejor ustedes ya saben o alguien
les dice que esto es deducible de
impuestos
pero la equivocación que he visto que
ocurre muchas veces es que las personas
creen que esta es una deducción de
impuestos que estos 10.000 dólares se
deben deducir de los impuestos en el
ejemplo anterior vimos este escenario en
donde una persona que gana 100 mil
dólares tendría que pagar 21 mil 720
dólares de impuestos y con base en esta
idea errónea las personas dicen nada muy
bien tengo 10 mil dólares deducibles de
impuestos pues ahora voy a tener que
pagar solamente 11 mil 720 dólares pero
que creen esto no es así la deducción no
ocurre en los impuestos que se pagan la
deducción sucede en los ingresos
recibidos así que si esta persona tiene
10.000 dólares de deducción en impuestos
en lugar de decir que tuvo 100 mil
dólares de ingresos dirán que recibió 90
mil dólares de ingresos recibió 90 mil
dólares 100.000 menos 10.000 la
deducción no ocurre en los impuestos
sino en los ingresos en ese caso sería
un crédito de impuestos la deducción se
aplica en el ingreso recibida
se refleja en este límite superior por
lo que la diferencia real con respecto a
los impuestos será la diferencia de los
10.000 dólares aquí en lugar de pagar 28
por ciento de estos 17 mil 750 será
solamente el 28% de 7.750 dólares es
decir no tendremos que pagar el 28% de
estos 10.000 dólares incrementales así
que nuestros impuestos con respecto a
este rango será que en lugar de hacer
esta operación de 17.750 por 28 vamos a
hacer 7 mil 750 por 28 pues el ingreso
reportado ahora es de 90 mil dólares
para obtener el número vamos a sacar
nuestra calculadora ustedes podrían
decir bueno voy a deducir estos 10 mil
en intereses entonces voy a aplicar el
28% a estos 10.000 y se lo voy a restar
a los intereses que ya calculé
previamente pero para mostrar cómo
funciona todo esto en su totalidad vamos
a hacerlo de esta manera hagamos los
mismos cálculos tenemos siete mil
setecientos cincuenta
por punto 28
mas 48.300 por punto 25
más 25 mil 600 por punto 15
+ 835 resultando en 18 mil 920 dólares
por lo que ahora los impuestos serán 18
mil 920 dólares y como pueden ver la
diferencia entre los anteriores
impuestos y los actuales es exactamente
de 2 mil 800 dólares porque ese es el
interés que nos ahorramos de estos
10.000 dólares deducibles de impuestos
si es que nosotros recibiéramos tanto
dinero bueno espero no haberlas
confundida